welcome to the Malden district council
webinar working safely in shops and
branches a basic guide to the new
working practices my name is Damien
Geller and I'm the lead specialist for
community at Northern District Council
who is this guidance for those working
in the retail and service sector such as
employers employees and the
self-employed the government sets out
five tests which if met will allow some
businesses to reopen to the public from
the 15th of June 2020 to help businesses
reopen safely the government provided
new information on how they should
operate when delivering services these
eight guides are there to help
businesses adapt to new ways of working
and consider how to implement them as
business owners it is up to you to
choose the best guide or combination of
guides for your business please note
that this guidance does not apply to the
hospitality sector and at this stage you
are still required to be closed once you
have decided to reopen your business the
government advice is for business owners
to carry out a risk assessment making
sure to consider the core and essential
functions of your business
Kenya services be delivered from home or
online rather than from site how many
staff are needed to operate the business
at a basic level
are there any functions that can be
suspended until things return to a more
normal situation do you have staff with
disabilities or protected
characteristics or special circumstances
that make them more vulnerable any
premises adaptations increased premises
clean regimes or protective equipment
please remember to share any risk
assessments you have made with your
workforce caring for your staff
encouraging social distancing as an
employer you have a legal duty to
provide a safe working environment for
employees when considering how to adapt
your operating arrangements
please remember to consider the
requirements of the equality and
diversity Act 2010 employers can
consider such things as offering
guidance and support on traveling to and
from work safely adopting hygiene
processes for staff when arriving
or leaving the workplace increased
availability of hand-washing and hygiene
facilities for use throughout the day
the use of fixed teams to minimize the
opportunity for virus transmission
adapting work benches or workstations to
promote side-to-side or back to back
working the installation of protective
barriers for staff stopping the shared
use of general consumables such as pens
or writing pads the suspension of hot
desking arrangements and/or the
increased of cleaning regimes for your
premises caring for your customers
encouraging social distancing as a
business you must consider the safety of
customers wishing to access your
premises when considering how to adapt
your business please remember to
consider the requirements of the
equality and diversity Act 2010 safe
accommodation of customers can include
such things as the increased
availability of hand-washing and hygiene
facilities for customer use controlling
the number of customers able to enter
your premises adapting your shop floor
by using a one-way system or widening
aisles increased cleaning regimes for
premises including changing rooms if
they are essential for the function of
the business increase cleaning for key
touch points such as door handles or
contactless payments increased cleaning
of high touch display items providing
counter services by the shop entrance to
reduce the need for customers to enter
the shop to buy goods and encouraging
the use of contactless forms of payment
continuing to care for your customers
encouraging social distancing answers to
some questions from business owners
within the Malden district can a cafe
place tables and chairs on their
pavement outside of their premises and
spaced two meters apart know as the
pavement space will be prioritized for
pedestrians unless by agreement with the
council and where the pavement has been
clearly marked as forming part of the
business are shops allowed to mark the
pavement for queueing customers again
though highway laws prevent the pavement
from being indelibly marked you may
affixed signage within your own windows
or on the outside of your prime
but please note that a boards are not
allowed can other shop queues pass the
shop boundary yes provided the queues do
not impact or block the flow of
pedestrians using the footpath if this
is a risk then marshalling may be needed
is it safe to use aircon units possibly
the science suggests that where possible
airflow should be fresh and not
recirculated can changing room
facilities be used for non-essential
clothing types such as proms or wedding
dresses yes but only if it is essential
to the function of the business and with
increased cleaning provisions caring for
your stock control the virus as a
functioning business you will have
regular deliveries pickups and turnover
of stock and consumables depending on
your service you may also have to deal
with returns of unwanted or faulty items
in order to improve safety within your
workplace you may wish to consider such
things as setting aside a dedicated room
or container for delivered items to be
stored safely for 72 hours before
handling arranging for returned items to
be cleaned and stored for 72 hours prior
to being placed back on display and
making arrangements for pickups to be
made from easy to access parts of your
premises thereby reducing the need of
couriers to enter your building
minimizing transmission control the
virus as a functioning business you will
have regular cleaning regimes for your
premises already in place the new
guidance places greater emphasis on
regular cleaning and methods for
lessening the chance of virus
transmission many instances businesses
will need new products or facilities to
help them make their businesses safe so
you may wish to consider such things as
installing screens to shield both staff
and customers who are moving around the
premises encourage the use of face masks
and gloves within your store installing
new signage which can guide customers
seeking to access your services
installing hygiene and extra sanitation
stations for customer use and consider
the use of online ordering or click and
Collect services accessing information
saving lives please remember every
business is different and this
information is for guidance only having
been adapted from various online sources
this advice is only applicable to
England and will be updated over time
you can find additional information and
support by accessing the following links
below
official government guidance can be
found by following WWE UK guidance /
working safely during coronavirus kovat
19 business support UK also offers a
range of reference videos and webinars
which can be found by following the
youtube link below and lastly thank you
for all your hard work and all the
services that you provide to the
community be safe